[Music]
a very good evening time then for the
press preview it's our first look at the
front pages of tomorrow's papers and
checking out the headlines tonight i'm
joined by the broadcaster former
government minister anna subree and the
pr consultant alex dean a very good
evening to both of you they'll be with
us of course until just before midnight
so let's have a look at some of the
front pages then we're going to start
with the i reporting that boris johnson
protected the former deputy chief whip
chris pincher who was today suspended by
the conservative party after being
accused of groping two men on a night
out
and the daily mail also goes with the
story about mr pincher so two does the
guardian as you can see
now the times reports on a new claim
against the now independent mp which he
denies
the daily telegraph leads on plans by
airlines to cancel flights next week
causing more chaos for tens of thousands
of passengers planning to go on a summer
holiday
the ft focuses on a warning from ryanair
whose chief executive says air travelers
face years of rising prices because
tickets have become too cheap
the express reports boris johnson is
backing what it calls revolutionary
plans to tackle the nation's housing
crisis
and reasons best known to themselves the
star tells us about a missing
pigeon
and reminded that by scanning the qr
code that you can see on your screen
throughout the program you can check out
the front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch us discussing them and
to discuss them i am joined now by anna
subray and alex dean now very good to
see you this friday evening thanks uh
for joining us and anna uh what let's
kick off then with um this extraordinary
story about uh chris pincher things
seemed to begin fairly well yesterday
evening when he resigned the first we
heard of it pretty much was when that
letter was released offering his
resignation
but then things turned a little bit
sticky didn't they for uh boris johnson
yes and to me the real story in this is
actually the way that it has been so
badly mishandled by the prime minister
and of course he has history on that
look i i knew chris pincher first of all
in 2010 and all i will say well two
things first of all these are
allegations when it comes to groping and
touching and those are serious
allegations they should be properly
investigated and frankly not necessarily
by the media but actually by either the
investigation um operation that there is
in the house of commons or by the police
and everybody frankly is innocent until
such time as they are proven guilty but
i i mean i have to say this i mean you
know my own view of chris is that he's a
troubled soul
and i hope and that it will be
understood that you know it's a good
argument he needs some serious support
through all of this because this is
serious stuff but as i say the real
thing is the way it was being mishandled
by boris johnson it's a serious
allegation and there were two tory mps
senior conservative women who quite
rightly said earlier on today that
johnson should have taken action
immediately and suspended the whip from
him whilst this muscle was properly
investigated and yet again it's another
cock-up and this
this over-protection and not dealing
with things properly
actually causes more of a storm for
boris johnson than the actual allegation
of sneeze if you like yet again
involving a conservative yeah yeah i
mean that's the point isn't it they if
if if uh the whip had been withdrawn
straight away then then boris johnson
would have taken credit for that and of
course he's now lost the opportunity to
have credit for something which
inevitably did 24 hours later and anna
just i'll get alex's view in a moment
but just very quickly when the prime
minister's spokesman says that the pm uh
wasn't aware of any specific complaints
made against mr pincher before he gave
him this job as deputy chief whip um
do you believe that
which is a question whether i believe it
or not i find it quite extraordinary it
may be a mark of the prime minister that
he's just not interested
in this sort of thing look the role of
the whips of course is party discipline
but there's also another role which is
the welfare and there has been yet again
a profound dereliction of duty
towards other members of parliament
staff
and indeed people who may have done
something very seriously wrong there is
a duty of care but chris has had
problems in my view for a long time and
those problems should have been
addressed and he should have been
supported and helped and he should never
have been made deputy chief whip and i'm
astonished if boris johnson's team
didn't know about those difficulties
okay plenty more analysis in the
guardian their headline questions for
johnson as tory whip uh suspended um
alex uh number 10 is saying that they
acted quickly uh once a formal complaint
had been made so he resigned
nothing uh
else happened until a formal complaint
was made and that's when number 10 say
they jumped in and decided to remove the
whip whilst the the investigation takes
place i mean is that not fair enough
yeah you're right on the chronology and
let's just be clear about what the sets
of accusations are chris pincher tonight
faces three sets of uh of issues or
problems or allegations the first being
that he was so drunk he couldn't control
himself which he admits in his letter of
resignation to the prime minister the
second is of of groping uh at the venue
and he has been silent on that his
letter doesn't uh address that and the
third is a new allegation about
inappropriate behavior on the front of
the times which his lawyers have firmly
denied
so there are those three different um
allegations when it came to the first
one about the um chris pincher being
drunk and incapable um there's some of
what anna said i disagree with but i
agree with her completely about chris
pincher he is indeed i think that phrase
troubled soul is a very good one and i
would venture to say it was pretty
widely known in the westminster village
so i agree with some of what she says
including the point about having a duty
of care to people who find themselves
under the spotlight in these
circumstances that is not in any way to
diminish uh the importance of this to
people who are or maybe his victims uh
there is a duty of care to chris pincher
now too
but the player i might disagree with
anna slightly and it's not i know she
and i have discussed the prime
minister's merits or faults many times
but this is not actually in my view just
about the prime minister i think there
is a systemic problem in westminster
with people who face challenges in their
lives like this
most responsible employers will say
we'll look after you we'll take care of
you don't go back to your desk you're
not going to do any more work and in
westminster the situation across the
parties and institutionally is the
reverse
this situation is we think you're an
idiot you've let everyone down now get
back and fight another election carry on
i mean that is a very good point anna
isn't it you know in any other large
organization there'd be a proper hr
department there'd be 360 degree reviews
there'd be structure there'd be a
complaints procedure there'd be that
duty of care but um as you well know um
having spent a lot of time there that
structure simply doesn't exist
yeah but it's not just in parliament
let's get this clear i mean it might be
in in great organizations like the one
you work for i don't know but there are
many businesses across our country where
there are all sorts of sexual assaults
going on that largely women who are
being sexually uh bullied effectively
and so on and so forth which we often
don't talk about that doesn't excuse
parliament because parliament should be
a shining beacon of how you do things
right i agree with you in fact we do
agree don't we alex that there is a duty
of care and there is a dereliction of
duty of care but let's be very clear
about this i can't believe that boris
johnson wasn't told that as i put it
chris pincher was a troubled soul
and and the the problem here is that
boris johnson appointed him as his
deputy chief whip for no other reason
than he'd been loyal to boris johnson
and organized some big dog rescue
mission when boris johnson was under
attack quite properly and instead of him
doing the right thing and resigning he's
clinging on okay uh we're we're going to
go to the break uh shortly and i just
want to squeeze this story in uh before
we do that on the front of the telegraph
alex um i mean we're going to see this
headline every day i think aren't we
more holiday chaos predicted uh as
airlines axe more flights
rotten news for travellers but the thing
about this jonathan is that at least
people know in advance what government's
now requiring these airlines to do is to
cancel flights they know aren't going to
go and perhaps because they're concerned
about losing slots if they announce that
far enough in advance perhaps because
they're living on a dream that the
flight might just possibly go or if they
keep you dangling you won't cancel your
ticket or you might have fewer rights if
your flight isn't cancelled they're not
telling people rights up until the day
so it's absolutely vital that airlines
tell people if their flights aren't
going to go i know it's really
depressing to see a headline like this
but it is better to know your flight's
going to be cancelled than to be kept
dangling in the way that some people
have been kept angling for the last
month yeah i'm a terrible scene
over the last few days um we've seen
anna quick thought from you on this
right so cock-up is now i'm sorry but
some of that responsibility must be with
with government because this was all
predicted it must have been anticipated
and i wish more had been done and that
includes by the airlines themselves i
just feel sorry for all those people who
haven't had a holiday because of covid
and we're looking forward to a break
this summer and frankly i think lots of
people are thinking oh god i was going
to stay at home and pray to goodness
that we have a great british summer
because prospects have been stuck in an
airport or flights cancelled
absolutely ghastly i do feel sorry for
people who have not had a holiday
especially those people who worked so
brilliantly on the front line yeah
through the code third year of
staycations the good news is the weather
is improving next week andy will be
pleased to know we're getting a few nice
days
coming up plenty more to discuss with a
32 increase in covert cases in the past
week have we become complacent about the
pandemic i wonder we'll be discussing
that in a moment
[Music]
welcome back to the press preview anna
and alex are still with us um alex
kovid's cases are going up rather
dramatically highest level since april
2.3 million
uh people are thought to have had it
last week
and we will all know people who are
caught up in this new wave i know
anecdotes uh isn't um the same as
statistics but uh gosh i know many more
people who've got it in this wave than
than in previous waves the important
thing to mention that uh in that too
though is that hospital admission rates
are not rising like anything like so
much as they were uh in the last waves
and i learned this morning as i was
listening to the nhs reports that um a
majority of people in hospital who do
have covid are in hospital because
they're being treated for something else
so this is a this is serious and it's in
part to blame for the story we were
discussing before the break about lack
of staff in transport systems because if
you test positive then you can't go to
work under the current regulations but
it is better i'm not being totally
complacent but it is better than we've
had it in the past yeah and it's these
omicron sub-variants they just seem to
be hanging around aren't they
yeah it's one in 30 isn't it i've got it
in england i think it's one in 18 in
scotland and this rise of about 34 seems
to be across the united kingdom i mean i
just think we just all have to be just
just aware of it keeping an eye but i
mean i did some filming earlier this
week i was quite surprised that
everybody was wearing a mask whether
they were being overly cautious because
you know you've got people who have got
to have the continuity you could have
somebody who you know has to go off and
isolate and so on and i don't know
because in the rest of the world it
almost it
in our country anyway it just seems like
it's not gone away but we're almost back
to normal and i mean i think that's good
news but we just keep an eye on it that
must be right yeah and i guess as long
as those um nhs um uh um
numbers uh stay steady then uh then
things are okay isn't it um we'll just
squeeze this one in as well alex front
of the daily express um there's not a
lot of detail here um just explain this
one to us
the government has a plan to allow
people to effectively pass on a mortgage
so you have a multi-generational
mortgage facing the enormous problem
we've got getting people onto the
housing ladder this is a pretty smart
attempt to think about things outside of
the box on the other hand one might
point out we are not building enough
homes and as long as that remains the
case the question will still be what are
they going to buy
hannah
he's right on that i just think it's
it's a bit of a gimmick isn't it i mean
the problem is actually
as alex says we
have a problem with not building enough
enough houses i didn't think it was
access to
mortgages and of course call me
old-fashioned but i thought you passed
on money and assets and
good things to your children not dead
yes a very good point imagine that
signing up for a 50-year mortgage okay
uh thank you both we'll speak again in a
moment uh right now we'll take a quick
look at the weather